welcome back i want to apologize that
last problem i think i've rushed a
little bit because i have to get under
this 10 minute
youtube limit um
but but let me know send me a message on
that last video if you if you don't
think the explanation was uh
as satisfying as you would like it to be
if you're still confused but with that
said let me move on
problem number nine
problem number nine on page four sixty
one problem number nine
say the decibel number above and they
were they wrote let's see they say five
point
one zero one
zero zero one
zero zero zero one
zero zero zero zero one and then it
keeps going the decimal number above
consists of only ones and zeros to the
right of the decimal point the first one
is followed by one zero the second one
is followed by two zeros right second
one is followed by two zeros third one
followed by three zeros
and so forth what is the total number of
zeros between the 98th
98th
and
101st
one
in this decimal number
well the first one is followed by one
zero the second one is followed by two
zeros the third one is followed by three
zeros right so the you know the 50th one
is going to be followed by 50 zeros
right that the nth one is followed by n
zeros so the 98th
98th is going to be followed by
98 zeros right
and then the 99th so you're going to
have you know a one then you're gonna
have 98 zeros then you're going to have
the 99th one
and that's going to be followed by 99
zeros
right that's just the pattern that they
set up
then you're going to have the hundredth
one
that's going to be followed by a hundred
zeros
and then you're gonna have the hundred
and first one
right and we don't care about the zeros
that are after the hundred first one
because they said how many zeros are
between the 98th one
and the 100 and first one so i mean
another way to draw it is you know we
had a bunch of you know we had a bunch
of zeros on this and then this is the
98th one
98th
and then we're going to have
you know zero
a bunch of zero we're going to have
98 zeros here
then you'd have a one then you're going
to have a bunch of zeros
this time you're going to have 99 zeros
this is going to be the 99th this is the
99th
one
then you have the hundredth one which is
followed by 100 zeros
100 zeros
and then you have the hundred and first
one and we don't care about the zeros
after it so this is how many zeros are
in between we just have to add up this
see eight plus nine is seventeen so it's
what 98 plus 99 is uh
207 so it's 307
zeros is that one of the choices
oh sorry i i'm doing my math to that 98.
see this is how i know it's late at
night and i should be in bed but 98 plus
99 is 197
plus 100 is 297
297 so that's how many zeros are between
the
98th and hundred first one in this
decimal number
problem 10
let me switch colors this color is
making me sleepy
number 10.
f of x
is equal to three minus two x squared
over x
for all non zero x then f of two
well we just take a two and everywhere
we you know f of 2 we're just taking a 2
and sticking it here so everywhere we
see an x we replace it with the 2.
so it becomes 3 minus 2
we put a 2 in there let me switch colors
for emphasis
whoops
2. squared
over
two oh what that's not the same purple
over two that's not the same point this
is it
over two
and if i wanted to just so you know
where that 2 came from that's f of
f of 2.
right everywhere where there was an x i
just replace it with a 2 and now i just
evaluate this
so three minus two times two squared so
that two squared is four
over two so
three minus eight over two
equals three minus eight is minus five
so it's minus five over two
and that is choice
d
okay looks like we have a geometry
problem for number eleven
image
okay problem number
11.
let me draw this
and there's two lines like this
and like this
and
these lines are perpendicular
x degrees
y degrees
this line is l this line is m
it says in the figure above
l is perpendicular to n
right l is perpendicular and this is a
90 degree angle
and x is greater than 90 degrees so this
angle is larger than 90 degrees so they
didn't draw that way so this is actually
probably angling down a bit which of the
following must be true
y is less than 90 degrees so let's see
if this is
so it's interesting because who cares
what's happening
up here right if you have a line let me
just draw it like this
let me draw it with the lines actually
let me draw it like if you have one line
like this
and then this line like this
if this is right here is x
x is greater than 90 degrees
and this is y
we know that these two angles are going
to be supplementary to each other that
they add up to 180 right x plus y is
equal to 180 degrees
so if x is greater than 90
x is greater than 90 then we know that y
has to be
less than 90
right
so
that's what we know is true we could
look at the other choices y is
definitely not going to be greater than
90. y is definitely not going to be
equal 9. if if y is equal to 90 and x is
greater than 9 then these two angles are
going to be greater than 180 degrees
which we know it can't be
n is parallel n is perpendicular to m we
know that's not true because if this is
90 degrees and this is also 90 degrees
but this angle is a corresponding angle
but it's not the same so they're not
parallel lines this line is actually you
know i should have drawn it like this
actually i drew a straight line when i
didn't want to it's going to be skewed
down like this right because this x
degrees is more than 90.
and then l is parallel to m and we also
know that's not the case for the same
reason so it's choice a
all right
let's see if i can fit in this last
problem within the 10 minute
window
problem number 12.
in the x y plane the line with the
equation
y
is equal to 5 x
minus 10
crosses the x axis
at the point
with the coordinates
a b so this is where it crosses the x
axis x
so it's where it crosses the x-axis
what is the value of a
okay
so when when something crosses the
x-axis what's the value of b what's
what's the y value
well the y value we know is is going to
be
0 right i mean i could i could draw that
if i draw coordinates
and if and if this is a line let me draw
the line if say the line looks something
like this
where something crosses the x-axis
that's going to be right here when y
equals 0. so all we have to do is set y
equals 0 and solve for x so when y
equals we get 0 is equal to 5 x minus 10
5 x is equal to 10
x is equal to 2. so this is the point
right here this is the point
2 comma 0.
so a
choice a a
is going to be equal to
choice d which is 2
which is the answer
i think that's all the time i have for
in this video because the next one looks
like i'll have to draw a table and so i
will see you soon